some things just don't go together oil
and water
gas and matches tequila and fireworks
so you can imagine my concern when i
heard about a combination
of kayaking and surfing
[Music]
then i saw this and thought perhaps i'm
worrying about nothing
and then i saw this
and realized i was right the first time
all right if we're gonna go treating a
kayak like a surfboard
we'd better prep on center of buoyancy
and hydrodynamic drag
to remain stable our kayaker keeps his
center of mass directly over the kayak
center of buoyancy
which is in the middle of its submerged
volume
traveling out to sea it helps to keep
the kayak perpendicular to the wave
because turning sideways can mean more
hydrodynamic drag
and a salty roll
when catching a wave he must ensure the
nose doesn't dig into the water
otherwise the resulting increase in
hydrodynamic drag
could produce a turning effect
waves can travel hundreds of miles
relentlessly building speed and power
before smashing into your kayak but we
should be okay providing
we remember the rules hold on a minute
should we be perpendicular to the wave
or parallel to it
[Music]
ah yes it was perpendicular
by hitting the wave almost parallel he
presents a large surface area
which leads to enough hydrodynamic drag
to flip the kayak
[Music]
we're out and ready to catch a wave i'm
videoing this just in case things don't
go well that's a little negative
confident confident
but well founded
good start but here the nose digs in
slows down and our friends
enjoy the benefits of the turning effect
now these guys have got it nice and
perpendicular
minimal drag
[Music]
like a knife through salty butter
[Music]
maybe it's safer to avoid all that nasty
drag and head out of the surf
to calm open c
oh look a delightful little fish
[Music]
you